>> Okay, good morning.
It's my pleasure to be
here. Thanks for having me.
And so today I'll talk about
a topic that I'm actually
very excited about,
which is dealing with
rare data in computer vision.
I've worked on
this starting from my PhD,
and I'm still continuing
with similar topic.
So why is it that I
like this problem?
Well, it turns out that actually
the world behaves like that.
For some reason it gives us
more data for some concepts
are very popular.
But for other concepts
we have only a few data,
or it is very hard to
collect data, right?
So for example, you can see
this on the 397 data set, so.
And then pull up
the histogram of
the instances that you
have in that data set,
you will see that
the living room, actually,
is the concept that has
the most instances to
actually work with.
But when you actually
find a skateboard park,
you only have a few
instances to work with.
To give you another instance
of this problem,
feature matching is
another good example of this.
So when you actually match
features from two images,
many of the candidate
correspondences
that you get are actually wrong.
So only a few portion of
them are actually good, okay?
So in nature,
these two correspondences
are actually rare.
Okay? And, well,
we actually have to learn how to
deal with these rare events.
For example, consider
a self-driving car, right?
Many of those systems,
for the perception systems
that they have,
very likely they have,
or they're trained
with, the common scenes
or common events of
the world, right?
But consider the case,
I don't know,
that this self-driving
car is actually
seeing this baby
crawling on the street.
It is a very unlikely event,
but actually do happen.
Actually when I was
creating this slide,
I found a few posts
in the news where
actually this happen.
So if we don't learn how to
deal with these rare events,
we can have horrible
outcomes, right?
So, I organized
the talk as follows.
So first, I'm going to talk
about what I did,
essentially in my PhD,
dealing with correspondences,
and treat them as rare events.
And then I will switch to
current topics that I'm
actually working on right now.
So the second one is learning
directly from
a long-tail data set.
And then the third one is mainly
just a visualization
framework for CNN's,
dealing with pixel level tasks.
But it has a relationship
with rare events.
Especially, I was
interested in seeing how
CNN's behave for input
that the CNN has
never seen before.
And then I'll just
conclude, okay?
So I'm going to start
with correspondences,
and the feature matching.
And this work essentially aims
to improve RANSAC-based
algorithms,
to make them faster,
but with a noble insight
of treating these two
correspondences as rare events.
And I'm going to
be using statistics
in order to model
those rare events,
in order to do so.
This was joint work with
other collaborators,
Sergio Rodriguez, Pradeep Sen,
and Matthew Turk, of course.
So image correspondence,
or solving this image
correspondence problem,
is actually fundamental
in computer vision, right?
So thanks to the solution
for that problem,
we can actually reconstruct
large 3D models.
We can actually
localize cameras if
we have a 3D model, for example,
or we can do image teaching,
and many other applications.
So it's an important problem.
As I mentioned before,
solving the image
correspondence problem
typically throws us data
that is not useful, okay?
So when you actually get
the candidate correspondences,
I will say that actually
70 percent of them
are actually wrong.
And so if we're lucky,
30 percent are actually good.
Okay? And this is because
many things like rotation,
elimination, scale variations
in the process of the camera.
So those factors actually
affect the feature matcher.
So it basically
confuse it, okay?
So the goal here,
or one of the first goals
when I started my PhD was,
"Can I actually predict which of
those candidate
correspondences is true,
or is a good one, based on
the similarity scores that I
get when I run
the feature match?"
Okay? And to give you the
solution that I came up with,
first, let me review, actually,
how is it that
the feature match works?
So imagine that I give
you these two images.
I want to reconstruct say,
for example, the Colosseum.
So the first thing
that you do is that
you detect your features,
which are visualized
with these circles,
and then you basically
forget about the context
of the image,
where that feature
was located, for now.
And then what you do
is that you only graph
patches surrounding
that feature, okay?
Then the next step is, say,
for example, that
you want to find
the feature matches
for this query feature.
What you will do is that you
will compare the representation,
say, for example, SIFT or SURF,
against all your reference
features that you
have in your database.
So basically this, this,
and nearest neighbor
group, right?
So you will have to, we
have to compute, say,
a distance between
their SIFT descriptors.
So you collect them, and then
what you do is that
you basically grab
the minimum and select
or establish that correspondence
following this rule, right?
So essentially just selecting
the most similar feature,
based on some appearance
representation.
So these scores are going to be
my random variables
of interest, okay?
I want to predict,
based on this data,
if the correspondence is
actually true or false.
So this is actually
the statistical model
that I came up with,
and the main idea is as follows.
So if I have
a minimum distance for
a true correspondence,
somehow that minimum distance
should be an outlier with
respect to the distances
of the false matches, okay?
So if we have
a good representation,
which in this case see if
there's a actually good one,
it has proven to be a good one,
then very likely
that score should look like
an outlier with respect to
the statistics of
the false matches, okay?
So overall, you can actually
think about that there's
an underlying process
with two distributions,
one distribution
that is essentially
drawing distances for
good correspondences,
and another distribution that is
giving you samples
for false matches.
Okay? So when you
collect these distances,
essentially when you run
your feature matcher and
you collect this set.
So it is equivalent,
or you can think about,
getting that data set as
drawing from this mixture model,
right? From these distributions.
Now since I'm actually
considering a 3D vision problem,
at most I can have
a correct correspondence, right?
That's because
feature matching aims at
identifying the same 3D point
depicted at two images, okay?
So at most I can have
one good solution.
So this means that, this set,
if I'm lucky and I have
a correct correspondence,
I'm actually drawing one sample
from this green curve,
which is representing,
in this case,
a true correspondences.
But then I actually
have a lot of
false matching scores, right?
Because there are other points,
and therefore I'm going
to get scores that are
actually coming from
this red distribution.
So the goal here
is that somehow,
what I want to do is
model this course coming
from this distribution,
because I actually have
more data for it, right?
For example, if you want
to fit a parametric model,
you know that you need
a lot of samples to
actually get a good estimate of
the parameters that
you want, right?
But in this case, if I were
to fit some model and try
to get some parameters,
I only have at most one sample.
So it's not going to be that
reliable for one sample.
Whereas in this case,
from the false matches,
it's reaching in data, right?
As I explained before.
So I can actually
work with this.
Oh, you have a question.
>> So is this the solution
for a single Y or infraction,
do you otherwise do together?
>> This is considered
only one query.
So, meaning that I
have one query feature,
and then I just
compare that query with
all the rest. So
this is only for one.
So rather than actually using
the entire data that I have
here to try to come up,
or estimate a distribution,
promise of a distribution.
What I'm going to do is
actually try to focus on
the minimum distance that
this process can
actually generate.
And that's because
the nearest neighbor matter,
it only focuses on
the minimum distance, right?
So the rule is
telling it to only
decide based on
the minimum distance
that you get out
of the sampling.
So, the goal is into model,
what is the minimum distance
that these process can generate?
And for that actually,
there are statistical
theories that give you
the distribution that
models that behavior.
So once I have that model of
the minimum distance coming from
these [inaudible] process, then,
I can actually do a test,
and check if the
minimum distance that I
have agrees with that model
that I just computed,
if so then, I can actually
predict that it is false.
Otherwise, it's actually a good.
That's the whole idea
of a research.
>> Do we expect the false
correspondent matches
towards the [inaudible]
>> Oh, that's actually
a good question.
So this is just an illustration.
I'm not assuming a Gaussian,
or anything like that.
This is just the state that
I have two distributions,
they may have weird
shapes, and so forth.
This is just to illustrate that
I am considering
two processes here.
Yeah. So, what I'm
going to use here is
something that is called
Extreme Value Theory It's
a statistical theory that deals
with maximum or minimum
of a random process.
Essentially, it aims to
give you the distributions
that will model,
either the largest scores
coming from a random process,
or the minimum score
from a random process.
And in particular
for this problem,
the theorem that works the best
is something that is called
the Block Maxima theorem.
It turns out in the linear,
you can proof that
the distribution that
models the minimum,
or the maximum is a distribution
called the Generalized
Extreme Value distribution.
So, it is actually
a very complex distribution,
but it is so
general that in the linear
it actually holds.
And according to
the theory it hold
for a lot of processes.
And it has special cases.
So one of those
special cases that
I'll be using a lot is actually
the Rayleigh distribution,
but others that are
common for example,
are Weibull,
Frechet, and Gumble.
So, just to give you an example
of how this theory works,
imagine that I have a normal
distribution in one [inaudible].
And then, imagine
this experiment.
So, I'm going to draw 10,000
samples from these
Gaussian distribution,
and then you keep
the minimum of that.
Then you draw another
10,000 samples from
the same distribution,
and you keep again
the minimum of that.
So you repeat that process
for that experiment
multiple times,
saving the minimum score
that you got.
The distribution
that is going to
model those minimums
is actually the GEV,
or the generalized extreme value
distribution according
to this theory.
So, what I'm showing here is
that I actually ran
that experiment.
So I drew these samples,
and I fitted the GEV.
So this will be the GEV,
the distribution modeling
only the minimum samples
that these Gaussian
distribution generates.
Does that make sense?
And just to give you
a bit of a nevertheless
that this actually works.
This is a sum of these,
but it's actually
plotting the histogram of
those minimums that I
stored when I was
running this experiment.
So, this is
a very general way to
more minimums and maximums.
It should be easy to
see that maximums can be
model as well because you can
turn maximum by just
negating that score, right?
So you flip it's
like an optimization.
>> So for Gaussian distribution
where is the
theoretically limit?
>> The theoretical limit?
>> For that
distribution minimum.
>> So, are you asking like if?
>> If you draw it from
a Gaussian distribution,
and you actually plotted
the distribution of minima.
>> Yeah.
>> Right. So is that theory?
What should the right
distribution should be?
>> The right
distribution is this one,
the generalized extreme
value distribution.
But are you asking about
the bounce like what would do?
>> [inaudible] is parametric.
>> Yes. This is parametric
model, but it's unbounded.
I mean these model codes here.
But it's actually very likely.
So what this is
saying is that most of
the time when you take
the minima from a process,
very like it's going
to fall in this region.
>> Right.
>> It's not telling you.
>> It's that like the equation
that you can write?
>> Yes. Yes, there is
a parameter for from it.
Yes. It's part of
an exponential family,
so it has scale shape,
and location.
So it's actually
a parametric. [inaudible]
>> Yes.
Yes. So this histogram
is the history of
the minimums that I kept.
And in the red curve there, you
see is the GEV that I fit.
Yeah. So, I'm going to use
this model for modeling
the minimum scores
of the false matches.
And then, I'm going to
use this to check if
the minimum that
the nearest neighbor matchers
using to decide,
agrees with it, or not.
So they actually the algorithm
it's pretty simple.
So, what we're
going to, oh, before
I move on here, I
forgot another thing.
In order for this to work,
we actually have to graph a
large number of samples, right?
So, imagine that
instead of graphing
10,000 samples,
I only graph two.
So the likelihood of- well,
the domain of where
those samples will
be very likely is
going to be around six, right?
So, if you draw
only graph two sample
very likely you will get a
common or what is
considered a normal value.
But when you grab
a bunch of them,
then your chances of getting
rare data from
the process increases.
So this theory essentially,
requires a lot of data
to make sure that
we have rare cases.
So that you can actually
fit these distribution.
So, back to the problem,
so this is the algorithm,
it's actually fairly simple.
So once you actually computed
all the distances comparing
all these descriptors,
the idea isn't to only focus
on those that are small.
But because I'm deciding
based on the minimum distance.
So in this case, I'm just going
to graph case small distance.
And then, the idea is to
fit an extreme value model,
based on the theorem
that I showed earlier,
but in this case,
I'm going to discard
the minimum distance.
And that's because if it
turned out to be correct then,
the model will have a bias
in implicit in the fitting,
right? And I don't one that.
But very likely, the remaining
points will come from
the false matching
random process, right?
That's because I have
a lot of data from it.
So then this estimate is
going to be fairly okay.
Then once I have
my distribution that I call
G in this case, by the way,
I'm using capital
letters for CDFs,
and what I'm going to do is use
this CDF to check
the minimum distance,
or the agreement with it.
So, my minimum
distance that I kept,
I'm going to evaluate
the way the CDF there,
and then, I'm going to have
another threshold that
going to help me decide.
So, if these value
which is some probability
is actually above
this threshold,
then I can actually predict that
is a false correspondents
because it's agreeing with
the model of
the minimum distance.
If not, then, likely,
I can predict that
it's a good one.
I'm kind of curious.
Can you go back.
>> Yes.
>> You say you need
a lot of samples.
>> Yes.
>> To compute that.
>> Suppose theoretically,
your sample is
close to infinite.
>> Okay.
>> Which means that
your minimum is
actually very, very, very small.
>> Yes. Yes.
>> That means that
the more samples that you take,
the more to the left,
the redcoats is
going to be like.
>> Yes.
>> I am talking
about theoretically.
>> Yes. Theoretically speaking,
you can proving
the limit that actually
will converge in
something like this.
What you're talking about is the
location of this distribution.
Yes. The sample will affect
the location of
this distribution.
For sure. But in the limit it
actually uses the parameter
from that [inaudible]
>> [inaudible].
>> To this one?
>> This is running per query?
>> Yes, per query.
That's exactly right.
Here it's fine because
typically when you
detect features,
you will get like
1000 features or 2000 features.
Of course, depending on
the scene that you're seeing.
If it's wall texture, you
will have a lot of features.
But if it's a wall
with no texture at all,
probably you will have a few.
But yes, this is run
per every feature.
This is the algorithm.
It's fairly simple.
The journalistic
values distribution
has some parameters that
are actually hard to fit.
It turns out that
the maximum likelihood estimator
has some nice properties only
under certain conditions.
But then if you don't
comply with it then there's
no guarantee of
maximum likelihood at all.
In order to avoid
any issues with it,
we decided to use
a special case of
that which is
the Rayleigh distribution.
It only has one parameter
which is the scale.
That totally minimize those
issues that I was explaining.
I'm going to show you
some experiments that I
did with some results.
For this experiment, I
used the dataset that is
widely used in the community.
It is called the Oxford
Affine Covariant dataset.
It's giving you basically
a bunch of images and
for every image, you
have homographies.
Remember, the homography
transformation pixel to
pixel from image
one to image two.
They give you this ground truth.
You can actually get
or determine what
are the right correspondences
when you do this experiment.
Thanks to this homography.
You can actually
run your matching
method and then thanks
to the [inaudible]
define which correspond
to [inaudible].
These are actually ROC plots.
True positives on the y axis
meaning that how good
my predictor worked
determining the right
correspondences.
On the X axis, we have
false positive rate meaning
the rate of false alarms.
Meaning that if the classifier
thought it was correct
but in reality it was not.
Clearly what we want
is a point that is
high in true positive rate
and minimum in
false positive rate.
In order to get this curve,
you vary the threshold
from zero to
maybe some high number.
For every threshold
that you have.
you have a point in this curve.
Okay. I'm actually violating
several thresholds at the same.
These are a couple
of baselines and I'm
comparing the proposed approach.
The proposed approach
is actually.
the red curve. We named
this male recognition Rayleigh.
On the left we have
for sift features,
and on the right we
have for surf features.
The main baseline here
is what I call lowest
ratio but also in the community
it is known as
the Sift Ratio Test.
That test is very simple.
When you do your matching,
you get your distances.
You divide the smallest distance
and the second
smallest distance.
That ratio is widely used in
the community to actually
filter about correspondences.
Then I used
another baseline just
to compare something that
is called the Brown's Ratio.
It was a paper CDPR.
Very similar to the sift
ratio test but instead of
dividing the smallest distance
with respect to the second one,
we take the average of
the second one and the third as
a denominator and then we
again compute the ratio.
That is the black curve.
There's another method that
is very similar to the one
proposed but it was proposed
mainly for visual
classification.
What they found
in a PAMI paper is
that the Weibull distribution at
least for those problems,
work well in another domain.
Here I'm showing that
the Rayleigh distribution
for future matching
actually works well.
As you can see here,
the red curve is above
the other methods which
means that this seems
to be working okay.
On average, you will see
an improvement of
three to five per cent.
If you just want
to predict through
correspondences by just using
the similarity score
of the six matches.
Okay. This turned out
to be really good.
The next problem that I
wanted to tackle given
this was to speed up
all the estimations that occur.
For example, in
structure for motion.
Once you have
these correspondences,
at the end of the day when
I get a 3D model or maybe
estimate a homography
or a fundamental matrix,
in order to do other things,
to understand for example
the relative motion
of cameras and so forth,
in order to do that,
we actually have to run
something that's called RANSAC.
RANSAC can be slow
especially if we
pass an image pair that
has only a few correspondences
that are correct
say for example,
five per cent or one per
cent, it's going
to take forever.
Just to remind you about RANSAC.
RANSAC is this iterative
algorithm where you have
your candidate
correspondences in
our domain but it's
actually more general.
You select randomly a subset of
the data then based on
that subset you fit a model.
Basically, you get a hypothesis.
The next step is to check
with the data itself and say,
"How many points in my dataset
agree with the model that
this hypothesis
that I just drew?"
You repeat this and you
always keep, it's like
a greedy algorithm.
You always keep the one that
is explaining the most of
your day of the kind
of correspondences.
Once you reach
a number of iterations,
you return the best model.
I wanted to speed that up.
RANSAC originally is
randomly drawing points
from your dataset using
a uniform distribution so
every point actually is equal.
But given this previous
knowledge of this predict a rate,
I can actually get a score
indicating which correspondents
are likely to be good.
This idea that I was evaluating
with a minimum distance
can be used as
an informative feature.
I can actually normalize that
and get a distribution over
the correspondences
and get some sort
of an important sampling
strategy to do so.
If I follow that
sampling strategy,
then very likely I can
speed things up because very
likely I will hit
the correct correspondences
and get the model very quickly.
That is the idea. Now if
we use this course from
the previous algorithm,
it actually works well.
But actually I found
out another way
to spin this a little bit more.
>> [inaudible] of
the distribution
is depending on the number
of samplings, right?
>> Yes. That's what
he was saying. Yes.
>> Is there any duration between
ratios, distribution
and sampling?
You need that knowledge, right?
You know that apply
the threshold or whatever.
>> Yes.
>> In this a ransom case,
you need if somebody has 10,00
correspondence about that
or whatever then you
can predict where
the distribution is.
Is that right?
>> In theory, I could. Yes.
>> Then how you can
apply that yourself, so.
The reason is in
order to determine
the threshold equation,
you have to know the
distribution equation, right?
>> Yes.
>> And that
distribution equation
is related to the number
of sampling, right?
>> It could, yeah.
>> Could.
>> Yeah.
>> Then how to determine
the threshold value after that?
>> Okay. The way I did it in
my experiments is that I
got a training set of liner.
I computed the threshold.
>> All right. Yeah, yeah.
>> Then I used that
in testing set.
>> Oh, yeah. Yeah.
>> But yeah, in theory,
yeah, I will have to do- I mean,
yeah, that will be
a problem as you described.
Luckily, in practice, we can
actually do this. All right.
So, just to continue,
I wanted to follow
a different strategy
very similar
to what I showed earlier,
but as Ganga, she was
mentioning the algorithm
that I presented is actually
for every feature, right?
I have a computer
for every feature.
Well, I can actually grab
the entire information from
all the features and
exploit it, right?
Essentially, if you have
these query features
and then you compare
with your reference features,
you can actually create
this matrix where you arrange
the distances such that
for it for this row, sorry,
where the rows are actually
corresponding to
the query features and then
the columns are giving you
or storing the distances that
you get when you compare say,
for example, this query with
all the database or reference
features over there.
Every column essentially
is a comparison, okay?
Every row is corresponds
to the query features.
Now, the predictor that I
showed earlier was working
only with one row, okay?
I can actually exploit
all these data and then
probably do something better
in order to gain more data,
all right, and
fit another model.
So, just remember that
the random variable
of interest is
actually the minimum
distance always.
So we're going to be focusing
on the minimum distance
of every single row.
What I want to do
here or the idea is
actually to come up with
a mixture model that
describes the statistics of
the minimum distance when they
run the entire match considering
all the information
that I have, okay?
I still have a lot
of data coming from
the false correspondences so
I should be able to
use CVT no problem.
For the true ones,
probably I won't have enough.
It depends on the images so
I cannot use CVT directly.
For that, I will
have to do something
else that I'll
explain in a second.
So what I came up with is again
another very simple
approach where I'm
going to assume
a mixture model of this sort.
This F is a CDF modeling of
the minimum distance that
I've observed when
I match my features.
It could be good or bad, okay?
It's similar to
the previous algorithm.
I'm also conceding
two processes.
One that is explaining
the correct distances, sorry,
explaining that distances for
the correct correspondences
and another one
for the bad ones.
You know that in
a mixture model you need
a mixture parameter, right?
In this case that
mixture it parameter
is called the inlier ratio.
That inlier ratio essentially is
that probability that if
you select a random one
candidate correspondence,
what is the probability that
that one will be a good one?
Okay? And so the mixture model
is actually fairly simple.
You will have two densities
that are mixed together.
Thanks to this inlier ratio.
This model is the CDF.
For the false match, again,
I'm going to use the GEV
because I have a lot
of data and I'm focusing on
minimums so therefore
I can actually use CVT.
For the ones that
are actually correct,
I may not have
enough data and I may
not be able to
model it with a GEV.
Here, we actually
had to look into
the histograms and
we determined that
the gamma distribution
was moderately well
the shape so here
we just use gamma.
Now, the importance of
a correspondence to do
these sampling forensic,
can be simply calculated with
a Bayesian approach, right?
If you do your Bayesian math,
you will use the PDFs
and you will get
a function that if you pass
the minimum distance in
question it'll give you
a likelihood that that one
is actually going to
be a good match or not.
This is what I'm
going to be using
for speeding up ransack.
Now, the problem is that
now we actually have
to recover all the
parameters for each
of these distributions
and the inlier ratio
from the data, okay?
In order to get
those parameters I
propose the following algorithm,
the first step is going to be
using the predictor that
I introduced earlier
and separate those
minimum distances that
are likely to be good
and likely to be false.
Then, for those that
are labelled as good,
I'm going to feed
a gamma distribution
and then for those that
are labelled as false,
I'm going to feed
the GEV distribution.
Then, the last
parameter that I need
to estimate is actually
the inlier ratio.
For that, I propose
solving the following
least cost problem.
Okay. Let me explain
how this works.
The V vector is
grabbing the empirical CDF
from the minimum sample.
If you grab all of
the minimum samples
for every row in the matrix
that I showed earlier,
you can actually call
a MATLAB empirical
CDF and I'll give you like
a CDF in numerical function
so you can actually
stack that up here.
Then, what this
is saying is that
somehow the inlier ratio is
the scalar that allows me to
linearly combine these two to
predict these value, right?
Then, it means that this e
when you multiply by
these matrix A should
be able to get me or
predict this value,
sort of like a
regression problems here.
In order to construct
these matrix A,
what I'm going to do is evaluate
the minimums that I got
and evaluate the CDF
for the good matches for what I
believe is using the model
that I just found out.
Yeah, for the correct matches,
and then the model
of the GEV for
the false
correspondences evaluated
at the distances that I have.
Then, I want to make
sure that some of
these guys which are
the scalers so that I can have
my model stated has
to sum up to one.
Then these was more like
a hack that allows us to
actually get better estimates
and I'll explain
that in a second.
This is basically
just bounce on the solution.
Obviously, this inlier has
to be larger than zero,
but it has to be upper bounded.
In theory, this epsilon
is between zero and one.
Then, we found out practically
that these tau which is
actually the inlier ratio
estimated from
the predictor that I
introduced earlier,
helped us to actually
force the algorithm or
the solver to get
with a good solution.
Sorry. Here I have a mistake
should be over epsilon.
Let me show you some results
with this algorithm.
Top row, I'm showing
for SIFT features,
bottom row for SURF.
These red plot here
is just showing
the histogram of
the minimum distances
coming from the false matches.
No, sorry, from
the true matches.
Then the red curve
is the curve that
I found out with
the proposed algorithm.
Then here, the blue one
is for the false matches,
this is the GEV,
the Generalized Extreme
Value distribution.
Then, when I solve everything,
this is the curve that I got,
the green curve, the
continuous curve.
Then, the histogram is actually
the histogram of the minimum
distance that I observed
by just grabbing the minimum
of this distance
from the matrix.
Now, this black plot
is the weight that I
get by just applying
the base formula to get
the sort of like
confidence on correctness.
Well, as you can see here,
at least qualitatively,
the fit is actually quite good.
It's actually not that bad even
though there are
a few hacks to make it work.
Now, this gives
a good general picture
that the algorithm is working,
but what about the estimates
of the inlier ratio itself?
Here, I'm showing
this table where I have
several image pairs and
I have three columns.
The column with no squiggle
or anything is
just a ground truth
so that's the ground truth.
Epsilon hat is
the estimate that I
get by solving
the least cost I propose.
And epsilon theta is a modified
this square except that
I don't have this
upper bound with
the tau that I was
mentioning before.
The observation
here is that if I
actually don't put
that upper bound,
the solution tends to overshoot.
So, for example,
consider this row.
If I don't put the upper bound,
actually the value
is super wrong,
so it overshoots; but when
I put the upper bound,
it actually would
behave a bit better.
You can see the same trend in
other image pairs even with
different descriptors
so this actually work.
>> When you put
the upper bound, do you
actually set up the bound?
Is your epsilon basically
the upper bound to impose?
>> No, it's actually different.
It's different from that.
It's lower than that, yes.
And yes, this made
it work better than
without the approval.
Okay. So this is just to
get the results of
the model, okay?
But then this is not
showing the speed of that
I can achieve with
the RANSAC approach.
So I'm showing this table
on homography estimation.
Our approach is
called the EVSAC which
is shown in this column.
We're comparing this with
RANSAC and other methods that
are also accelerating
RANSAC converters.
The most famous one
it's actually PROSAC.
And I sorted the results,
so as you can see at this table,
every rows have
different image pair.
Here is some data.
So, for example, this first row
is using SURF features,
then the second row
is SIFT features.
And here is the number of
correspondences that I got.
And then this Epsilon is
the ground truth
for that image pair.
So this means that
only one percent of
the candidate correspondence was
correct according
to the ground truth.
And I saw them, okay?
So, the lowest inlier ratio
to the highest inlier ratio.
So these are too many numbers,
but I want you to focus on
these boxes that
I'm highlighting.
So, what you can see here,
for example, consider
the first row.
Models means the number of
hypotheses that the algorithm
had to draw in order to
reach to the good solution.
And then time here
is just milliseconds,
the number of
milliseconds that it
took to actually convert.
So, what you can see
here is that actually,
EVSAC thanks to this model,
it only took 4.2
milliseconds to actually
reach to a solution.
Compared to for example, PROSAC
which is actually faster,
but the number of good runs
means that out of
the 300 trials that I got,
EVSAC, 100 percent of the time
returned the same answer,
which was good.
But PROSAC only,
less than one percent
return a good solution.
Then the remaining results
were completely wrong.
So this means that EVSAC
tends to be more
consistent than others.
And of course, in this case,
RANSAC took forever
and never converts,
and so, never return
a good solution.
You'll see the same trend
as you go down.
So, EVSAC is very
competitive especially when
the inlier ratio is very low.
But when you start getting
a higher inlier ratio,
meaning that you have
more good correspondences,
then EVSAC tends to behave
on par with
the competing methods.
Okay? So the real
advantage here is,
when you have an image pair that
is not that well behaved
in terms of that,
we don't have
the many inliers, okay?
Now, that actually
comprise the part of what
I did or what I tackled
as part of my PhD.
And then I'm going to talk
about some other topics
that I'm recently working.
And these are actually results
that I haven't
published yet formally,
but I just want to show
where I'm going and
what I'm thinking in
terms of research now.
So, I'm going to
show an approach
to learn from
a long-tail dataset,
and this is work that I did with
Deva Ramanan from
CMU last summer,
although we are
still working on it.
The motivation came
from this picture.
He's very excited about
the Open-World Problem.
And then I got
excited about it as
well because it deals
with the rare data.
Clearly, the problem
if you actually train
say a network
using this dataset,
very likely, the network
is going to bias, right?
It's going to do very well for
the classes that have
a lot of samples,
but it's going to do poorly for
these concepts that
only have a few samples.
So, this problem is actually
different from
a fissure learning.
Because here, we
are actually trying
to tackle both problems
at the same time.
So you have concepts that
have a lot of samples,
but others that only have few.
So how do make
the network world behave
well for both of them
at the same time?
Now, also the community hasn't,
or doesn't have
a good evaluation protocol.
So, another contribution
that we believe is
useful is a protocol that
we're proposing here.
Some previous work on
that that are tackling
this can be categorized
as follows: So,
sampling-based solutions
essentially say, well,
if you have this
unbalanced datasets,
well try to balance it.
So you can probably undersample
some classes and
try to come up with
a training set that has
fairly the same number
of training instances.
The middle learning approaches,
they are actually
very interesting.
So what they do in
a CNN is that they
train another module that
predicts the grading updates
for the classes that
have only a few samples.
Okay? And then
some other problems
that are actually very
related, fissure learning.
Well, these are actually
fairly recent but each of
them is very different.
And then cost-based,
essentially,
is imposing penalties in
the optimization problem, right?
It's going to penalize
the classifier if it's actually
doing a poor job
for classes that are
not well represented.
So what we're proposing
is something very simple.
We wanted to come up with
something simple because that's
what people adopt
more easily, right?
So the idea was, yes?
>> A question, sir. In
all of these examples,
you have images and labels,
except that you don't
have a lot of [inaudible]
>> Yes exactly.
So yes, this picture.
>> There is no unlabeled data?
>> Yes, there's no unlabeled.
Everything's labeled
except that you
have for some more than others.
So what we propose is,
can we learn on embedding
that allows us to deal
with this thing on balance?
And the idea came
up mainly from
a Gaussian mixture model.
If you think of
every single concept
that you want to learn,
and then it's represented from
a single Gaussian distribution.
You remember that in
the Gaussian mixture model
you have this priors
that somehow are
encoding or can encode
the imbalance in
the dataset, right?
So the idea is to
have that model to
then take that out of
the equation and see if
the classifier will do
better if we somehow twiggered
to ignore that imbalance.
So, the idea of
these embedding is actually to
represent each concept
with a single centroid.
And hopefully, the network will
learn a function that minimizes
the inter-class variation
so that we can
have a compact representation
for all the instances per class.
So here, I'm just giving you
an example of how this works.
So, cats are very popular
on the web. Cars as well.
But when you search
for a white reindeer,
it's very unlikely that you
will find many pictures.
So, that's the overall idea.
And one of the benefits
that we thought this
could have is the
following: compared
two linear classifiers,
you have your linear
classifier and
you have a new
training instance,
say, for example,
falls in this region,
then very likely,
this new instance
is not going to
give you an update
of your parameters because it's
already classified correctly.
But when you add
another instance
using this
center-based approach,
then very likely,
that center has to move.
Okay? So, it is actually
very sensitive to that.
And we think that this
is actually a benefit
of our approach.
So, in order to learn
these embedding,
we proposed this
optimization function.
So, classical
cross entropy loss,
where we have the embeddings and
w are the parameters
of the network.
And then we have the centers,
one center per class.
And then if you only consider
this part of the equation,
essentially, is just encoding
the newest class
mean classifier.
Which is very similar
to the nearest neighbor.
It's just going to assign
the class to the closest mean.
And then, we added a regularizer
here just to make sure
that these centers
which are actually
optimized or learn
using regular deep
learning methods,
just so that it complies
with the statistics of
the embedding as you run
your optimization process.
So here, this term is
just grabbing from the mini
batches computing
the center from
the mini batch and then
enforcing that the estimates are
close to the center
that is being estimated from
the deep learning framework.
So this is the objective
function that we proposed.
As you see, it has
some relationship with
linear classifier which
makes it easy to implement.
And the relationship is
the following: If you
expand this quadratic term,
you will get this,
and then as also you directly
establish a relationship with
regular softmax classifiers
with the exception though,
is with this bias over here.
This bias is actually
constrained by these terms.
So, the bias is actually half of
the center of the class
that you have at hand.
This term actually can be
factored out and
then cancels out.
So, the relationship with
linear classifier
is that essentially,
we're fitting linear classifiers
where the w
represents the center,
and then the bias section
restricted by the norm
of the center or
the norm of the center.
This is useful for
implementation details.
Now, in terms of
the evaluation protocol,
what we propose is
the following approach.
So, we have
the imbalance dataset,
and what we want is actually
to capture and see if
the classifier generalizes well
for classes that are
not well represented.
So, what we proposed is to
actually sample the
training set multiple times,
and then for every sample,
train a different model.
Now, that I have those models,
I'm going to use the balance
set in order to make
sure that the
classifier is actually
generalizing given
this different samples.
This is just of measure
and see if I have
a class variation for some
concepts, can this generalize?
And then normally,
you just plot the report
of the per-class
accuracy average.
So, out of those trials
that you had,
report just the average for
those trials for every class.
That's what we proposed
in comparison with
other methods which
are just train,
and then evaluate
using as if you
had a balanced dataset,
which may not be right.
So, here are some results
on small-scale datasets.
I compare this with
other center-based approaches.
One that was recently published
at CVPR 2017 was iCARL.
Essentially, iCARL graphs
are soft Max,
computes all the features
for all the classes
that you have,
and then it computes the center
for every class, and that's it.
So, there are two versions:
one that is on normalized,
which is what I just described,
and then normalized means
that all the vectors that
you are dealing with,
they have to be normalized.
And the reason that they
used it, according to them,
is that actually helps reduce
some noise effects in the data.
Then I just used
the regular GMM approach.
After I have the
Softmax representation,
I fit a GMM,
and that's it. Those
are the baselines.
So, on the right,
you will see the accuracy,
the average of
the Softmax classifier.
And as you can see here,
for example, for MNIST,
you know that MNIST is
actually a balanced dataset,
I actually had to
long-tail them,
to make it imbalance.
So, as the index grows,
the imbalance growth
here in the plot.
So, as you can see here,
the average or the accuracy
drops when that
imbalance occurs.
This shaded region is
just the standard deviation
that I got from the trials.
Now, the plot on the left
is just showing
the relative performance.
That means the accuracy
that I got from every of
these methods divided by
the accuracy that I got
from the Softmax classifier.
This is just to clearly
see if there's
an improvement or not.
Where there's an improvement,
you get something
larger than one.
If there's a drop,
you will see points
below this line.
So, in the MNIST case,
most of them
actually behave okay.
And that's because this dataset
is not that complex.
But once you actually
analyze other datasets,
for example, five or 10,
you will see that actually
the center-based
approaches especially
improve the accuracy on
those classes that
are imbalanced.
Well, you can see that
actually, the polling is hard.
So, softmax tends to bias
a lot from classes in the head,
meaning those that are
very well represented,
but it does very poorly
with classes that are not
very well represented.
Now, when we increase
the scale of the datasets,
so it'll be harder to note
improvement here though.
But there is some improvement.
So here, if you look closely,
the black dots are
actually above the line
which means that we're
actually observing
an improvement
thanks to the
center-based approach.
And same here with
another dataset
that is called Tiny ImageNet.
So, this is the proposed
approach and you will
see some dots that
are above the line.
So, which means that this
approach is somewhat helping.
And just to clearly emphasize
what's going on here,
I summarized
the relative performance
for classes in
the head and classes
in the tail for
different methods.
Here, I didn't consider
the Gaussian mix
and model, because
actually as you saw,
it is not performing well,
and for all the datasets
that I consider.
So, for the head,
the proposed approach is
actually showing
some drop in performance,
but it's actually not that much.
So, it's very close to Softmax.
But when you look at
the classes in the tail,
you can see that number
is actually larger
than one which means
that there is on
average some improvement
in terms of classification.
All right. So, this is one of
the current projects that I
have I'm still working on.
And then I also
want to talk about
another project
that is visualizing
a few things from
CNNs that are used
for pixel-level tasks.
This is also work
done with Chunhui Liu,
Aayush Bansal, and Deva Ramanan.
And let me give
you the motivation
of why I wanted to do this.
So, we humans actually can
learn very easily from
even a single example.
Right? But we also have
the ability to say,
"Hey, that object I've
never seen before."
Right? So, we have that ability
of discovering new things,
and then learn new things by
just experiencing the world.
That's something
that I would like
to enabling in computing.
So, some idea that
I got was, well,
maybe I can actually discover
that new knowledge assuming that
that new knowledge
somehow looks like
an outlier of the
already known knowledge.
And I already have theory as I
showed earlier using
the feature matching problem.
But the problem there
is that the theory that
I showed earlier was using
the nearest neighbor classifier,
and then CNNs are
somewhat different.
So, somehow I have to
establish this link
of the nearest neighbor
classifier in CNNs.
So, that's what motivated
to study this problem here.
And so, we introduce
something that is called
the Compositional
Nearest Neighbors
approach to visualize
what's going on here.
So, I assume everybody's
familiar with
Pix2Pix and maybe
results of SegNet.
So, on the first row,
I'm showing label
to images where
the ideas that you pass
the labels of
a facade in this case,
and then CNN will generate
an image that agrees
with these input.
The Compositional
Nearest Neighbors is
actually something
that is very simple.
So, if you grab your train CNN,
and then you grab the last layer
of your convolutional
neural net,
and then you grab
a specific patch
corresponding to one pixel
and use that as
a feature descriptor,
then you can actually search for
the nearest training patches
in your training set,
and then create this image
that looks a lot
like what the CNN is
actually generating.
Even though it's
noisy, that may be
because of the parameters
that we used,
but somehow, we are able to
replicate the results of CNN.
So, this is using Pix2Pix,
this is using another CNN
which is SegNet.
And as you can see here,
if you just compare these two,
they overall tend to have
similar behavior even though
there are some artifacts there.
Now, this column, it is
classical nearest neighbor,
where you will represent
the entire image
using some bottleneck feature
of your architecture,
and then just retrieve the most
similar image from
your training set.
So, just to be clear, say that
I want to synthesize
the value of this pixel,
what I will do is
grab a patch from
the last layer of the CNN,
use it as a feature descriptor,
and then search in
my training set.
So, in this case, I'm
visualizing that I've found that
maybe this is a window
that looks like this.
And then what the compositional
nearest neighbor is doing is
just grabbing the information
from the training pair,
grabbing the RGV value
here, and copying it here.
Okay? What is nice
about this approach
is that this allows us
to get correspondence.
Meaning that, I know why
this value is maybe brown,
and that is because
it's coming from
these training set that is
very similar to in
appearance at least.
>> So, you do this
is for pixel on
average with patches
with overline?
>> Yes, not at this time,
but that's one of the steps
that we're considering.
So, right now, it was sort
of like a proof of concept
of seeing if this is
actually working or not.
And somebody is actually
replicating the results.
For example, something that
caught our attention was,
why is it that the CNN
is drawing this red,
I don't know what that is,
but this red region.
Well, we find that
it is actually coming
from this image that has that.
So it's somehow is
actually replicating that.
And so, we came to
the conclusion that maybe
it's memorizing
the training set somehow,
and then it does some sort of
a fast and nearest
neighbor synthesis
which is similar to what
we're proposing here.
These are more results
on the same idea.
Datasets are Facades,
CityScape, and CamVid.
So, these are
results for Pix2Pix.
These are for SegNet.
And so, as you can see here,
Pix2Pix and the Compositional
Neural Networks,
they actually tend to look
very similar to each other.
Same here for SegNet.
And so, it looks
like the networks are
memorizing somehow the dataset
and then replicating
that information.
And some interesting feature
as well is that,
that patch that we're using
as a pixel representation,
we know for sure that actually
encodes sort of
global information,
but also local information.
By global information,
I mean for example,
the color of the Facade.
And for the local
information, for example,
what kind of window style
are we rendering.
So somehow, the network
is able to figure
that out and embed
that information there.
More results on other datasets
from labels to images and then,
from images to
Google Maps like images.
So, as you can see here, we
replicate a very,
very similar result.
Now, another
interesting observation
that we saw here is that
what if instead of rendering
the expected output
given by the pair, right?
Because there's
image translation,
can we reconstruct
the input image
using the same approach?
And it actually turned
out to be good as well.
So, if we use
the same representation,
but reconstruct the input
from the training set,
we can actually do so.
So, for example, consider
this row over here.
We were able to
input this image,
which has never seen
before by the CNN,
and then by doing this
Compositional Nueral networks,
we can actually reconstruct it.
It actually resembles
the scene very well.
So, this is something that got
our attention and it
looks like the
presentation is so good
that it is even encoding
things from the input
that is allowing us
basically to just find
the information from
the training set,
and they just copy and paste in
the information as
the final output.
So, this happens
also with other type
of data like labels.
>> So, you don't have
any smoothness constraint
>> Yeah. Yeah. Nothing.
Nothing like that.
>> How do you make sure
the patches are coming
for the same image?
Why isn't there different
colours or different
>> That's what I'm was
saying here before,
that if somehow
the network learns that,
so it contains
this global information
exactly of what color were
the Facade we're rendering,
what kind of style of Facade.
But also local information,
the windows information
for example,
what kind of window is it?
Is there a glass there?
So, these are intriguing
results that we're
still working on
this. But, yeah.
Now, the last experiment.
If you're familiar with Pix2Pix,
they're using
a unit architecture.
And it has this
Bottleneck and then,
you have a lot of
the decoding layers.
So, it looks like
that the network is actually
using the Bottleneck to
retrieve similar images and
probably use the most
similar one as the basis.
And then, as you progress
over the deconvolutional layers,
somewhat is morphing the output
by adding more details,
and details, and
details until you reach
to a final output.
So, for example, this peak
that you observe here,
which is the output of
the deconvolutional layer,
it can be explained that it
came from the most
similar image.
Okay? So, it looks
like the CNN is just
morphing for
every deconvolution that
you're actually doing until
you reach the final output.
So, we're still working on this.
We have more experiments
in one of the next steps.
>> So, I can understand
this deconvolution.
But, Bottleneck, how do
you configure bottleneck?
>> When you do the Forward pass,
you will get deactivation
of the Bottleneck and use
that as a whole descriptor
of the entire.
>> To start it to process?
>> Yes, exactly. It looks like
it's grabbing the
most similar in.
>> As we go through
the convolutions
here, you're also grabbing.
>> Patches.
>> Smaller and smaller?
>> Exactly, yes.
That's exactly right.
All right. So, that is
actually pretty much it.
So, just to give
you some conclusions
of what I presented today.
So, I hope I convince you
that Extreme Value Theory
is actually fairly,
well, it's a good theory
to model rare data.
I showed that with
a feature matching.
It allows us to predict
good correspondences
and also speed up
robust estimation.
In terms of long-tail datasets,
it looks like center-based
approaches are, I mean,
it's giving some insight that
the we maybe up to
something there,
but we still need to
work on that more.
And then, these visualization
framework to understand
pixel-level task from CNNs
are still intriguing, right?
And so, now, with all these
unseen inputs to the network,
we can explain how it
will behave at least
using this framework that
I introduced. All right.
So, that actually
concludes my talk.
If you are more interested about
some other projects
that I have in AI,
or search for more information,
feel free to stop by
my website, vfragoso.com.
And yeah, that's pretty
much it. Thank you.
>> So, I think we still
have time to do
a little more questions today,
anymore questions
from the audience?
>> So, this last set
of results you had,
the network was trained
on Segmentation data?
>> Yeah.
>> So, those are
the sort of outputs?
>> Yeah.
>> Right?
>> But when you look
at your results,
it seems like you've
reconstructed the image.
>> Yes.
>> Fully. So, what
happens if you give it
Random Segmentation data?
If the Segmentation data
is not correct,
it's just random [inaudible]
>> We haven't tried.
>> Will you still get the same?
>> I don't know how I'd
probably be able to answer that.
But, I assume that
it will do the
best to actually replicate
the results based on this. Yes.
>> So the labels
don't really matter?
>> It looks like it's
not. I'm not sure.
I take it with a grain of salt.
I'm not sure. I'm not
sure what will happen.
That's why I'm saying,
we're still working on this.
I don't want to
give a bad answer.
No. But, it's very
interesting. I believe.
>> More questions here?
All right. [inaudible] Let's
thank our speaker today.
>> Thank you.